und jetzt gucken wir doch mal was ich da
wo auch immer es geht und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem kleinen unboxing
gespickt mit euren fragen die mir oft
gestellt habt und zwar habe ich ein
paket bekommen was fünf paketes ist wäre
der gleiche fahren im video
als allererstes eine wunderschöne frage
die wir hier auf twitter gestellt
bekommen haben von dem weltberühmten und
renommierten wirtschafts und weltmeister
japan platte der da fragt dem haue
fragezeichen und ein über kämme lässt
kein dm hall sondern ein päckchen von
der dkms und wir machen immer so ja ich
darf nicht oben auf dem bildschirm
schauen schwierigsten aufgaben in meinem
leben im film mit der realität
bildschirm zu schauen sollen die linse
ok alles gleich ob wir das projekt
meister 3000 links in der beschreibung
gestellt dass alle über amazon unter
kriege ich sehr viel geld für ohne
öffnen das jetzt einfach mal hier ich
habe neben dran da unten
mein laptop offen weil twitter auf
meinem handy funktioniert alte jurist
kennt keine apps installieren die partie
und der browser modus wird auch nicht
mehr deswegen machen das jetzt alles
über den laptop so und ich werde aber
wie gesagt zwischendurch eure fragen
einen ball an ihren dieses video
blablabla aber neue brüste und zukunft
noch mal einen tee es machen oder er
nicht 90 es ist geplant
tomic hat mir ein angebot gemacht das
ich nicht ablehnen kann über den fifa 12
zloty es oder so skype will mit auch
gerade im hintergrund weise über das
gehört habe habe die mikrofon
sensitivität mal ein bisschen oder
gemacht von dem teil
deswegen sollte das eigentlich gehen
dass ihr das gar nicht gehört hat so
das paket ist übrigens von käfern diesem
feinkost versand laden handeln versand
ist es nicht aber der feinkost anbieter
und ja das ging an mich so werden die
massen produziert das bekommen würde
ich hab das mal bei einem kollegen
gesehen und jetzt bin ich gespannt was
drin ist
ich sehe schon gute sache ich setze
heute einfach mal die lehrer mit einem
stativ 1
dann würden beide hände frei zum
auspacken habt was wahrscheinlich eine
eher nicht so sinnvolle sache ist okay
ist ein brief looki looki looki lotterie
alles für einen großen appetit mit
diesem genießer corp möchten die dkms
ihnen ganz herzlich für ihre
lebensspende danken ja vielen dank gebe
ich zurück gern geschehen
und jetzt guck mal hier robert ewig viel
von diesem zeug nicht abgehetzt die bude
diese prämierung schmeißen und auch die
luft bläst in folie die müssen
verbessert worden
das ausleben kann
ok also es ist das päckchen jeder kann
ich nämlich das paket mal weg stellen
wie gesagt macht verhalf rückte kommen
ps kommt wahrscheinlich muss ich dann
auch mit komik absprechen ob in japan
gefragt wirst auf dem video days sein
wenn ihr köln berlin oder beides ich
glaube die video days in berlin sind im
mai oder so ich hatte endlich am
liebsten würde ich auf beide gehen
wirklich muss mal schauen ob ich bei
halbzeit hat so einmal im mai habe ich
vielleicht noch uni dann später im
august glaube ich den können da habe ich
dann ja da habe ich verlieren aber dann
habe ich auch über den urlaub
hereingelegt wfc
wie war dein alltag vor youtube zu also
zum beispiel hattest du mehr zeit mit
deinen freunden verbracht julius 99 oder
schlecht sah es nicht unbedingt ein
bisschen bisschen mehr schon nach vorher
doch doch klar
gerade wenn ich jetzt abends live
streams mache habe ich halte ungefähr
überhaupt kein reallife mehr aber es
auch schon who weißt du wie sie max
nicht mit ihr zusammenziehen will fakten
alisha weil die weiter zusammen so einer
wg wer schon weiß ja finde ich auch aber
der max da würde ich mir zusammen ziehen
gewöhnlich mit einem party machen
weißt du was mit ihm los irgendwie
ich hoffe dass jetzt nichts drin wo bio
draufsteht
wir wissen natürlich erstmal besser
würde habe ich ganz vergessen und wir
jetzt gucken wir doch mal was ich dabei
kauft macht das sieht nice aus
ich will das gar nicht aufstechen
quatsch machen diese schleife auch
sicher dass auch richtig so hier
spiegelt natürlich meine songs mit
gestellten die küche wir das geschäft
ausgerichtet ist ein bisschen was
kleines outfit
so fällt es an boxen auf jeden fall und
das ganz ohne die amber rose derweil
weiter nach twitter fragen gucken
reingekommen sind ihr bier bier bier
bier was ist mit der 25 km spende
passiert das natürlich auch eine
interessante frage für viele ich weiter
geradelt wo es jetzt endlich so
verblieben dass er das jetzt den
kleineren stücken
ich weiß gar nicht wie viel 2000 oder so
spenden wir und einfach damit das mal
ins rollen kommt das ganze damit ich
noch sagen kann ja es ist lächerlich
finde es echt und so weiter und so vor
also wir sind jetzt alle erstmal pesto
richtig weiß ich bin es ist alles viel
verkehr vor
ich bin auf jeden fall ein absoluter
profi danke an käfer für dieses tolle
produkte getrocknete tomaten
das ist auch richtig dass hier das alles
ein bisschen italienischer whisky food
kette balsamico also ein balsam essig öl
einfach sehr gut warum auch in jeder
küche
ein native olivenöl chili ich hier sage
ich gern überhaupt nicht gerne scharf
das haben die glaub ich vergessen habe
ich extra gesagt heute steht mir nicht
scharf ist
aber irgendwie tomatensoße hausgemacht
ist für mich als student natürlich genau
das richtige weil ich einfach immer
etwas zu essen zu machen und dann
läuft's oft auf 0 hinaus natürlich super
wenn jetzt passt also ein pesto piste
und posten im haushalt parmigiano
reggiano grüner papagei muss man
eigentlich auch haben bruder parmesan
ist auf jeden fall wichtig und hier
ricotta mit steinpilzen was sagt ricotta
risotto und ist ein risotto hier aus dem
glas checke ich mal ab das ist glaube
ich auch ganz ganz nice jetzt graben die
meine und woher das noch mehr dass noch
mehr
oh ja
natürlich haben die leute gedacht der
typ ist so lebensunfähig das reichlich
über den menü soße schicken wir müssen
dem auch die nudeln selbst schicken
deswegen hier spielen die brawns bronze
raffinierte pasta treffen hergestellt
weiß jemand was bronze raffiniert ist
ich habe bronze bronze raffinierte es
ist bronze trusted raffinierte okay ich
hab mir die kommentare aus bronze
profilierte pasta ist oder bronze dran
france geht raffinierte bronze trophy
truck auf jeden fall auch sehr nice ist
da noch was ist da noch was roja da ist
noch was da ist noch was und das fühlt
sich sehr gut an
schokolade bürger will kommt was steht
drauf 3 colonias aviva aber trägt das
sind drei colonias arriva
das heißt 13 kolonien nach oben macht
wenig sinn aber gut schokolade ist
schokolade zartbitter schon bei 100
prozent ist eigentlich für meinen
geschmack ein bisschen zuviel ruhig mal
wieder fragen einbilden und einbilden
ich bin mit meiner frau ein ok eine
eingebildet aber ein bisschen glück gibt
noch ergebnisse kunde ich muss mir
jedoch genauer einbilden
gute frage von michael kapp unterstrich
es geht sagt wie lange denkst du dass
dieses täglich stream dingen noch
vereinbar mit union privatleben ist mein
lieber mit oder michael das war's noch
nie
also täglich strömen ist mit uni
privatleben einfach nicht vereinbar
ich mache da einfach bewusst abstriche
bei endlos geil finde youtube auch mal
weitermachen will
also verweist nicht wirklich so aber
geht es so ich glaube das war es aber
das war schon hier
dieses nette feinkost paket vom käfer
was ich da bekommen ist wie sein also
nicht dass ich denke es wär wie fordert
placement oder so das habe ich wie
gesagt von der dkms bekommen für die
knochenmarkspender so als dankeschön ich
fast noch mal zusammen also wir haben
eine tomatensoße pesto sehr gut
die olivenöl risotto mit steinpilzen
auch wenn ich nicht so der steinpilz
nicht die besucher fern sind getrocknete
tomaten parmigiano und balsamico sehr
wird alles klar und das war es auch
schon wieder fallen deswegen nicht sagen
was gerne daumen nach oben da wir euch
das video gefallen hat wir sehen das
nächste video wieder haut rein macht's
gut